Kim Davis the renegade Kentucky County
Clerk was sent to jail for refusing to
issue same-sex marriage licenses since
the Supreme Court ruling in June Davis
has said she wouldn't issue marriage
licenses to gay couples because of her
religious beliefs under my authority our
United God's Authority I thought we were
a secular nation we have no
state-sponsored religion and you don't
have to be of a certain faith to run for
office but wait we do have in god we
trust' written on our dollar bills under
God on our Pledge of Allegiance and
politicians unable to end a speech
without saying these words good night
and God bless alone and God Bless
America god Bless You God bless this
country we love maybe Davis is just
confused God is everywhere so what's the
deal here doesn't the First Amendment
allow her to freely exercise her faith
well according to First Amendment
scholar dr. Charles Haynes Davis's case
is not about simple religious
accommodations she has the right to
exercise her fake boolean openly as a
Christian but as a public employee she
has agreed to limit her practice and to
carry out the duties of that office if
those two come in conflict that she
needs to resign so Davis can freely
exercise her religion like asking not to
work on the Sabbath or wearing a
headscarf on the job but as a government
employee she can't infringe on others
constitutional rights like the right to
marry the same goes for other state-run
institutions it's illegal to promote
religion in a public school for instance
but okay what if Davis wanted to invoke
her religious liberties as a regular
citizen who didn't work for the
government could she say refuse to bake
a cake for a gay couples wedding in a
lot of states yes she could refuse this
is helped by what are called Religious
Freedom Restoration Act laws or
reference these laws generally give
their citizens more leeway in invoking
their religious
but if she happens to live in a state
with non-discrimination laws that
include sexual orientation she probably
couldn't refuse to bake that cake
non-discrimination laws historically
have generally trumped religious freedom
claims but Kim Davis isn't alone two
congressmen have introduced a bill that
would allow government employees to
claim religious exemptions the whole
debacle has now become a talking point
for presidential hopefuls only two of
the 17 GOP candidates had urged Davis to
resign but Rand Paul Marco Rubio and
Bobby Jindal supported her religious
convictions Mike Huckabee said this I
thank God for Kim Davis and I hope more
Americans will stand with her so there
you have it that separation of church
and state we hear so much about not as
straightforward as you might think you
could say we're actually a very
religious nation but at what cost to
each other